[Musique]
pour cette femme espagnole qui souhaite
rester anonyme avorté a été un cauchemar
il ya quelques années elle vivait aux
canaries à lanzarote aucun établissement
ne pratiquer des ivg sur cette île de
150000 habitants
j'ai dû me rendre dans la clinique d'une
autre île sur celle de gran canaria car
à lanzarote il n'y en avait pas je n'ai
rien dit à personne pour qu'on ne me
pénalise pas au travail j'ai donc dû
prendre un jour de repos et
une situation fréquente aux canaries
mais aussi dans toute l'espagne sur les
50 provinces que compte le pays aucun
avortement n'a été réalisé dans 11
d'entre elles un déséquilibre
territorial dont elle a été victime
la cndh a commencé j'avais l'impression
qu'on se moque et demain ce droit à
l'avortement sur et gratuit devrait être
garanti n'importe où des qui vient à un
centre de santé si une personne a des
difficultés à accéder à un droit alors
c'est un privilège
seuls 15% des avortements sont pratiqués
dans des structures publiques pour cause
la grande majorité des médecins en vo
qu'une clause de conscience pour ne pas
effectuer diverger lors de cette
manifestation pro vie ils défendent
cette objection
c'est un droit fondamental le droit de
croyance dans la médecine publique nous
sommes beaucoup de professionnels à
penser qu'il ne faut pas aller à
l'encontre des foetus
le gouvernement socialiste étudie la
possibilité de créer une liste des
objecteurs de conscience l'enjeu
s'assurer qu'il y est assez de médecins
pour garantir le droit à l'avortement
partout en espagne une liste dénoncée
par les médecins étudiants présents pour
la plupart des familles je suis la voix
de la majorité des professionnels de
santé ne fait pas de liste d'objecteur
de conscience car vous n'aurez pas assez
d'enfants
ce sont donc les 200 cliniques privées
subventionnées qui réalise 85% des
avortements cette structure a été la
première à pratiquer ses interventions
en espagne la fête charest la holding la
grenade
sonia la masse y travaille comme
psychologue d'après elle la formation
médicale dispensés pour pratiquer des
ivg n'est pas suffisante une formation
qui est pourtant obligatoire selon la
loi
aucune communauté autonome espagnole la
forme ces professionnels de santé
aujourd'hui on est face à un problème de
relève générationnelle
elle critique la stigmatisation dont
sont victimes les professionnels du
milieu
le jour où je souhaiterais ne plus
travailler dans ce milieu mon cv aura
une tâche indélébile travailler dans la
pratique de l'avortement nous
marginalise c'est certain temps à ses
autres combats de sonner à la masse
lutter contre les groupes
anti-avortement qui militent
régulièrement devant la clinique
parmi eux quaranta diaspora la vida 40
jours pour la vie durant la période du
carême ces catholiques se rassemblent
devant le bâtiment pancartes à la main
mercedes a bad vient dès qu
on ne vient pas harcelés ou parler aux
personnels de la clinique au maire et à
leurs accompagnants on vient juste prier
ses larmes la plus puissante que nous
ayons
ce mouvement est actif dans huit villes
à la fin de leur mobilisation les
bénévoles se félicitent de leur résultat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au congrès la majorité parlementaire
souhaite que ce type d'action puisse
être sanctionné en tant que délit de
harcèlement une proposition de loi a été
écrite mais pour cette jeune militante
ce serait une injustice
importante à beaucoup de droits le droit
à la liberté d'expression la liberté de
réunion la liberté de culte on ne peut
pas aller en prison ou avoir des amendes
parce que l'on prie
à l'origine de la proposition de loi
cette députée de la majorité socialiste
elle souhaite inscrire au code pénal ces
peines pour harcèlement devant les
cliniques
ils seront punis de peines de prison de
3 mois un an et de services rendus à la
communauté
un texte source de tension au parlement
lors des débats vous pouvez prier autant
que vous voulez mais laissez les femmes
exercer leurs droits
lors de cette séance elle est
interrompue par un député du parti
d'extrême droite vox hostiles à
l'avortement votée nous enseigne aux
jeunes une scène qui l'encouragent à
poursuivre son combat contre les groupes
devant l'ecc linking penta ils essaient
d'empêcher que les femmes puissent
accéder à une prestation reconnu par la
santé publique espagnole en fin de
compte ils harcèlent les femmes qui vont
chez le médecin
le camp socialiste au congrès espère que
cette loi pénale pourra être voté dès
l'an prochain en obstacle deux mois pour
l'avortement espagnol
[Applaudissements]